foreign
Hillside by the way
that's how we're starting the episode
well I just I think he's a queef he's
like I have boundaries I would never
hang out with a guy like that but you
would hang out with him shut up ah you
wouldn't hang out with Jonah Hill wow
all right you hang out with Matt Ruby I
wouldn't date him
come on all right Ruby's got some bad
hats I wouldn't hang out with him I mean
I'd hang out with him but I wouldn't uh
it'd be in a relationship with him I
mean look at this he's dressing like his
girlfriend that's got a long hair I
don't know the whole thing yeah but I
bet he's I bet he's you know I'm sure
he's fine I bet he's on drugs or
something to be that thin now the drugs
I like now we're getting somewhere great
comic actor is there a great comic is
there like in the last like 10 years of
better comic actor yes in like big
screen movies
well what about Will Ferrell in the last
10 years Will Ferrell's run he's great
but his run is like the early awesome I
see I mean that run of like Talladega
elf yeah uh old Anchorman old school
Step Brothers that was like a step the
other guys I feel like that was all
the early odds to like around 2010 or
something yeah we have Wolf of Wall
Street he's funny oh he kills that 21
and 22 Jump Street cured anti-Semitism
yes that's right Kanye loves him so I'm
all for the acting I'm all for the funny
but the the texts were just like cringy
to me it's all look no one's but you
don't want to see my text with my lady
too that's weird as well exactly no one
should no one's Tech should see the
light of day I feel like unless unless
you know I mean I don't know once you're
in a relationship I feel like that's a
weird add a context text like what he
wrote isn't great obviously
context yeah okay con Comic-Con but it's
con artist all right thanks for that
that was helpful trying to get somewhere
he's like word play let me see what I
can do here chili con queso
no it's whatever this is the dated story
anyway we're talking about but I think
you don't leak text that that's a that's
a violation of trust you put it public I
mean that she should be in trouble for
that as well this wasn't this wasn't a
Mel Gibson voicemail yes exactly this
was I don't like well it's like guess
what if you don't like that you don't
have to date the person and she doesn't
have to date you it it's just weird I
guess to date a surfer and not want her
to post swim swim photos right well that
that was crazy I think he's just like
hey don't show your ass and people like
but she's in a swimsuit all day long
he's like I know but if she's at the
club showing her ass it's a little
different I don't know I would never
text my lady that
it's all weird but I just hate how we
can't have two bad people everything is
so absolute He's the bad guy she's the
bad guy no they both suck two things can
be true yeah I think also the timing was
a little questionable like it did it did
come off like she's maybe not over him
yeah like better like he moved on has a
family with didn't they just have a baby
she didn't like that so it's I think
sometimes maybe that you're like well
he's not good it's tough when it's a
famous person you date because the
public perception is so positive so
that's probably hard to process a
breakup when you have all these negative
feelings of course of course but doesn't
excuse the not at all I'm saying I'm
trying to understand yeah yeah it's good
to understand but he sucks she sucks
they all suck they deserve it I like him
I like Jonah Hill I like him too make it
look like I'm less attacking the ladies
because they're allowed to attack men
without any uh repercussion but if you
attention later
consolations social media went back
there are two sides or no Defenders but
you know that's what happened when you
when you bring the flames on someone
some of the Flames are going to come
back on you you got that right there's
something really annoying about Twitter
now like I feel like when it started it
was uh funniest jokes and light word
play and like dead babies and rape jokes
and now it's literally now it's people
the minute people realized outrage was
currency yeah yeah yeah outrage performs
like
I don't know how many percent better but
way more it's like well that's what it
all became it just it went from like
everyone being like we didn't boom to
like yeah yeah I'm like well that's a
shitty place to be you wouldn't want to
hang out with that person but then all
day you're just like um
crying crying okay yeah I completely
agree but we do it with everything you
know you go oh that did you see what I
hear what Trump said it was so funny oh
you're all right now I'm like it was a
funny line I don't know I still think
he's a psycho it's a funny why can't
that we have Nuance you know and that's
that's what this does like he's a piece
of [__] he's a woman hater he's a
misogynist like he's texting his
girlfriend I don't know and no one knows
come on that's why that's why you
usually solve it with each other but
that's when someone's famous
true people become obsessive with this
[__] because are you careful with your
text now like anything you write like
yeah write something I'm like no all N
word no no I mean that was just to me I
mean if you look at this my wife showing
me her clam it's a tit shot it's me is
this joke funny she's like this is
appalling you know it's uh it's it's
wild our text drain train is wild and uh
if she ever leaked it I'd be crushed
just because it's like a
it's a violation of what we have that's
going to be one hell of a divorce oh the
[__]
when that comes out in the courtroom cut
to Mark ripping up the prenup all right
take it yeah let's take everything
please don't release those no it yeah
I've definitely look we've all ridden
[__] we're not proud of in a
relationship let's come on that's what
Texas both sides come on it's uh there's
bad people on both sides here here
that's all I'm saying yeah so
I forgot our original point but
yeah when it's it's tough when it's a
situation like this that probably did
have Nuance yes as opposed to like a
Chris Brown situation where she's just
covered in bruises and you're like okay
pretty much open and shut case right
here I don't know what she says that is
true we didn't get to the bottom of that
but
yeah no I agree I'm with you on that
yeah she couldn't even open one eye and
uh people still go on his shows so let's
let's be a little easier on old uh Hill
dog there you go all right and then was
that oh lizzo is how we got started on
this oh you're talking off camera about
lizzo yeah yeah I was telling my wife I
was like why am I delighting in this
cancellation so much because I hate
cancellation but I was like what I what
is it that I like and she was like well
you know you don't like fat people and I
was like it can't just be that it's got
to be more than that and I think I
figured it out last night and I think
it's that you know she's up on Mount
Pius and people put her up there it's
the only Mountain she's hiked
I thought she was the mountain all right
and she's up there with like inclusion
and like uh deposit body positivity and
everything and then like if you don't go
along with that sermon then you're the
bigot right and you're the [__] right
and you're the bully meanwhile the whole
time she was the [__] and making me
feel bad about it yeah yeah of course
but this is how it goes this [__] can't
last because humans are human and we're
all flawed no one's perfect we think
because you point a figure at one guy
now you're off the hook but you're still
a piece of [__] too it's like when I do
a dark joke people go you're an [__]
I'm like you've never had a dark thought
I just said mine out loud yeah am I
really the only psycho in America and
also also yeah I mean it's Madness but
also with Liz I mean I remember talking
to a comic once we had this big New York
Times write-up saying what a genius he
was and I called him I was like man
that's so cool and he was like I [__]
hate it because he's like that's when
they come for you uh that's when they'll
still call me a hat because he was what
he was saying he's like when they lift
me up like this it's not wrong it's not
wrong I mean people love to lift people
up and not lizzo but uh
but no they do love to lift her up and
talk about you know uh
it also is the same people that lifted
up that are the ones bringing her down
right now that's how it goes it's gonna
come for you this [__] comes for you so
stop coming for others you [__] well
she is an interesting one because she
you're right she's like a body
positivity thing and there's this weird
thing now with like the Liberals are
obsessed with
body positivity and sure it's good to
accept yourself that's good but at the
same time now you see articles I forgot
which publication it was but they were
like why is the far right so obsessed
with Fitness I'm like health is a is a
partisan issue now exactly why can't why
are you there's a lot to go after the
far right for you're going after
exercise I know again with the absolutes
It's All or Nothing if you're healthy
you're all right if you're fat you're a
liberal it's so stupid there's Nuance
some people are chubby like you you know
you're a Centrist okay but you're not
even that chubby sorry I couldn't go to
Matt but uh but you know it's just it's
these absolutes you know you got to go
all the way here this is all right so
this must be and white is bad black is
good that's so stupid and it's childish
and it's ignorant and we gotta have this
actor because he's uh Chinese they're
like what that's a little offensive none
of it makes sense it's all gonna come
crumbling down and I can't wait for it
and I'm not gonna forget who pointed
fingers
yeah man well uh it's uh it's also just
like it's funny how quickly you see the
fatigue of the mom where they go from
Jonah Hill and then it's like give it a
new cycle right right and then they find
the next one and before by the time this
podcast comes out it'll be a new person
it won't be a little anymore and people
will forgive her and she'll you know she
won't make her her new dancers walk to
Brooklyn to get a slice of Cheesecake I
think that was the accusation
I need to be walking
in trouble sorry everybody get ready to
hit the edit button but everybody
preaches compassion and hey you say you
call somebody uh trans or whatever and
they go hey that's insensitive blah blah
you know what else is insensitive trying
to ruin someone's life and take their
livelihood away and smear their name and
ruin their reputation that's insanely
I'd rather be called a a hack or a homo
or whatever come at me with the insults
it's fine
that that's fine but if you try to ruin
someone's life because they're a sexist
or racist or whatever and you don't even
know the facts that's shitty too what's
interesting is what Mark is saying is uh
please translate well yeah first off no
one's offended by being called trans
yeah but like I know you mean like uh
transmission fluid you know that's
offensive yeah a man's Mission fluid no
but uh I know what you mean where it's
like as kids we were taught to use our
words right and wow good point and now
words have taken on like another level
with social media and like how much
you're gonna you settle things with your
words I was like you're like Mom I
didn't fight I settle things my words
and she said good job okay you grow up
how do you settle things I smeared
someone and ruined their life right well
those were words
you know what I mean I think about this
too I was trying to do a bit about this
last night about how um you know Elon
Musk and Mark Zuckerberg want to fight
and how it's so childish that these two
billionaires just want to like fight
each other but then they're like it's
for charity and everyone's like all
right it is for the veterans I guess you
know and I was thinking like how long
before kids catch on to this they're
just wailing on a kid outside the
classroom the teachers tried to break it
up they're like this is for St Jude's
Children's Hospital we're trying to
raise money here yeah right but it's
like it is interesting to me that like
you know words
that's what we were taught but there
wasn't like guidance it's kind of like
being told you can be whatever you want
there was there weren't like guidelines
like use your words but words Sticks and
Stones Stones everybody knew that right
limerick
yeah it's uh it's not good and and then
the worst part is they use the under the
guise of them hey let's call this guy a
racist and then we can uh [__] him over
and we won't be in trouble even though
we're lying about what he did we won't
be in trouble because we're stopping
racism so now you're using an important
movement for your own personal gain
which is doubly shitty it's you may you
get mad at a guy making a black guy joke
but now you're using this this cause to
get just to get get rid of a guy it is
all about them that is way worse than
the black joke originally and they know
it God but it's but it all it began when
outrage became currency
when we started rewarding you know
people going look at this when that
started getting 200 retweets each time
or more yeah going viral uh that's when
yeah that's when it was exactly what I
don't get is like when Amber Heard says
Johnny Depp beat her up and then it
proves in court that she hired a makeup
artist she hired a bunch of people to
lie for he never did it he had to go
through hell and pay millions of dollars
in legal fees and be publicly shamed and
all this [__] and then it comes out that
she lied why aren't the women coming
after her hey look at this [__] lying
that hurts the movement too so get mad
at her yeah then I went to see his band
and it felt like an assault in my ears
so it's you know
you see my point well you'd still hit it
though Amber Heard of course I'd hit her
joking but yeah I don't know it's uh
it's all a bummer and I I think the
fatigue is real and I think we're gonna
look back on these times and go oh that
was wild because you know you ever see
Game of Thrones I never watched it
actually it's not my cup either but I
watched during the pandemic I heard it's
good it's good it's well done it's got
something for everybody but I hate
dragons and all that so uh there's one
scene where the big Queen she's like a
hot blonde lady Rich powerful Queen of
the whole land she basically gets
canceled they find out she did something
wrong and she has to walk through the
town naked and everybody's throwing
Tomatoes at her it's kind of like the
stocks remember the stocks yeah yeah
it's just that people are throwing [__]
on her and jizz on her and all this
stuff and true they really did you saw
it yeah and it's basically her getting
canceled and you're like
uh you guys think you're high and mighty
because she [__] up but you're
throwing jizz on a lady you know and
that's the same [__] you're just getting
off on throwing [__] on a person and
it's not because of Justice You're just
excited about oh we get the [__] over
the queen I'm a peasant and now I'm
[__] over the queen you know and it's
that's it's misplaced rage yes you're
not working on stuff translate
I need you here because otherwise I just
don't go [__] weirdo on a lawn no I
mean we see it all the time it's you
know you see in the street in New York
you just see misplaced like someone just
snaps to someone on the subway and
you're like that wasn't about her yeah
you know what I mean but we but that's
everywhere but people do it way more
yeah it's behind the keyboard with Jonah
Hill like that wasn't that those
releasing the tweets wasn't about the
tweets it was like let's [__] this guy
it's cowardly to do that to somebody
when you know there's gonna be no
repercussions for you and that that's
like a scenario where that happens the
tweeting where you know they never go
back to that person well let's look into
this person his life right because so
often those people have skeletons of
course we've talked about this [__]
before whatever but you know I got to
tell you did I send you oh you got the
clip we can't show this okay we
people know what I'm talking about
that's the queen they shaved her head
like that dude that's literally poo
throwing at her she's crying
so I would rather go through this than
get [__] online
this is it ends you know and the the
[__] online what happens to afterwards
does she just go back to being queen or
is it yeah I think she does actually now
she has to face Parliament or whatever
the hell but it's a hell of a scene and
uh it's worth a watch I heard I should
watch it it's well done j r r
there's an R all right what are we
Pirates all right but check it out it's
pretty good
all right well we we got that out I had
a day man I just I got here like 30
minutes early because the damn
Construction in my building I I [__]
you're not I think I sent you a clip of
what this looks like this has been 10
months it it is taking all the strength
I have not to write very bad words the
building manager look at this outside my
window play it oh geez you got the blue
tarp going like Katrina oh my Lord
that's my window it's been almost a year
this is this is comical I didn't know it
was this bad it's insane I mean this is
like uh the Malaysian miners trying to
get out of the the mountain here this is
crazy
oh my God I feel the vibration dude my
apartment is vibrating and it's here's
the best part they're doing it on all
sides of my apartment so there's no room
I can go in to get away so I just can't
be so this is the best part I go outside
today to just get I'm like all right let
me just get out the plumber stood me up
today I had a great thing the Plumber's
supposed to come by and it's such a New
York story already the plumber stands me
up ghosted by a plumber well here's the
best part my building's like this is who
we use so you should use them because
they know the building I was like all
right fine so I I swear to God I looked
them up we can look up the reviews it's
like
30 straight one star reviews literally
everyone is like you know they did a
badge of my Plumbing the next one's like
they raped my mother I'm like this is a
bad plumber apparently but that's my
choice I guess so they stand me up I
call I was like you're supposed to be
here they're like nope and I was like
nope wow nope and she goes you never
confirmed and I was like the guy said
yeah we'll be here Monday at nine yeah
and uh and she goes you have to confirm
I'm like he didn't say anything about
confirming he said I'm in the books they
were like sorry oh wow all right
whatever so I go out I take a walk to
get out of this noise and uh this is
bananas oh and they keep telling me it's
gonna I know they keep telling me it's
gonna end yeah no people are listening
to this man Jesus Christ I'm telling you
how insufferable it is and he's like let
me play it for a fourth time here this
is like Oppenheimer and IMAX that was
not as loud as this oh my God it's awful
it's like robotic so then so then I uh
we're gonna get comments like shut the
[__] up uh so I go outside to get a
coffee I'm like I'll just for a minute
you know and uh
immediately a crazy guy walks up to a
woman and he's just like he I sort of
got he clearly tweaked out I've seen him
in the neighborhood before he's he has
not improved since I've seen him last
goes up to a woman with a little dog he
goes [__] you [__] your shitty dog it's
like and she's like a pretty cool New
York girl where she's kind of just like
rolling her eyes but he's in her face so
I like walk up next to her just to make
sure
you know like he doesn't swing on her or
something sure so we just kind of walk
up and I'm like this is crazy uh then he
walks up to some other guy and he goes
[__] you [__] your mother and I'm like
this dude is a lot all right so I'm like
all right whatever he kind of walks away
same spot something about the Spider-Man
I guess another guy walks up to me he
does a thing where he's like because
it's someone who goes buy my book what
there's no picture we don't know what
the book's about I don't know the same
guy no a different guy rather than the
[__] you guy than buy my book no this
guy I don't think the other guy is
published
but he just goes up buy my book and
everyone's like no I'm sorry and he's
like buy my book and I could tell he's
coming to me so I you know I I turn my
chair I put my hat down and I have my
noise canceling headphones on you know
clearly inviting a conversation sure he
comes over to me goes buy my book and
I'm just like I'm I'm good and he goes
[__] her damn I don't I don't know the
path to be an author I don't think this
is it that wasn't our Tolkien
Jesus wow so that's why I'm here early
today I was like you know what let me
just get out of the neighborhood for him
and I'm in a good neighborhood that's
it's like a great neighborhood great
neighborhood for a crazy person yeah
that book guy's a bit maybe buy my book
yeah
it's like the J Sherman Thing by my book
remember that yeah yeah wow you got to
go on Amazon and leave a review about
that guy oh my God no dude it was a
morning but I'm like also it's like you
know New York you're used to that but
you're just it's like it's like that
comical yo you got it
the best [__] the most underrated if you
think of one show that got prematurely
canceled it's all day ah the best the
best and a smart show like references
they go back to like Orson Welles and uh
you know [__] Citizen Kane and all
that [__] but wow buy my book oh it's
beautiful brutal but I'm so happy to be
here I was like I I can't wait for this
pod today because holy [__] man well
yeah get it all out this is New York
it's so funny I had the opposite night I
had a tough fly a tough flight
connection barely made it from Des
Moines it was the whole thing finally
made it home you hit wall-to-wall
traffic there's a tanker truck flipped
over on the I-9 or whatever so you got
to take the back roads from Newark
brutal took me like an hour and a half
to get home from the airport finally get
there and I made a cocktail and put it
in a Starbucks cup just so I wouldn't
look like a weirdo and I just though the
ladies out of town I said let me walk
around the city I walked around uh the
village it was last night last night
beautiful night it wasn't Chris bear
every restaurant was full I'm walking
down Perry Charles Bleaker just glasses
clinking people laughing good looking
people everywhere went down to the water
had a great time cut to buy my book
that is a nice thing that's that's a
good wreck is to take put a little drink
in a different container take a stroll
oh yeah music going it was great can you
tell us about that night where you had
something to think about and you just
went out for a walk and you sat on a
bench in Manhattan oh yeah sure so I got
I had was having some problems with the
lady you know marital strife and uh
right it's tough we had a blowout for
all blowouts like blow out plates throw
it I'm sure the neighbors called the
cops like just ah and everything came
out everything this is what I hate about
it I couldn't live in your building with
that noise that's nothing compared to
this yeah oh yeah that oh God that is
wild it's like Darth Vader coming I
don't know what that is it's too much
um but uh so we just had it out and it
was like too much was said like too much
honesty and uh so I think it's a men and
women thing where she's like all right
let's start I said I'm leaving I gotta I
gotta take a walk and here's a weird
thing I walked outside I'm on Sixth
Avenue it's like four in the morning
we've been fighting for hours oh you
know one of those where it's like you
change rooms fighting you know like
we're in the bed and we're in the couch
or in the kitchen and three rooms that's
it okay well that's New York
I called her a [__] in the kitchen with
the with the the [__] butter knife so
so then uh I'm sitting on a park bench
just like headphones in look at the
phone you know you still got that
[__] energy going your adrenaline's
running from all the fighting and I'm
sitting on a park right now the bars are
coming out it's 4010 405 in the morning
and all these drunk gals and the village
it's like full of beautiful women it's
like yeah smokes amazing and I'm sitting
on a bench and I'm doing AC Slater style
I'm up on the top bench with the feet on
the on the foot on the butt part and all
these women are like coming up to me
they're all drunk and they're going home
and they're probably mad they didn't get
laid and they're going like what's up
with you why are you all alone now
they're sitting next to me and I'm like
God my whole 20s I was like trying to
get laid going to the gym pick up lines
uh swipe it on Tinder I had to just sit
on a park bench I felt like a like a
like a worm on a hook and I think do
they recognize you no recognize and
they're all like Hey Big Boy you know
and I was the the meat I was the victim
like they they would be like a pack of
five of them and they'd be like what's
your story why are you sitting here I
wish I knew this 10 years ago I would
clean it up you're about to inspire a
ton of creepy listeners right yeah maybe
yeah maybe you're right just hang in
Central Park dude yeah his marriage is
almost over we found a cheat code well
it kind of like lightened my spirits
goes like well this is very flattering
it's a guy I was like this is awesome
like so many women are paying attention
to me and talking to me these are like
really pretty ladies and I think the
fact that I was not hitting on them I'm
just minding my own business sitting on
a bench you know not bothering anybody
yeah what is wrong with these women that
they walk up to a dude sitting on a bark
bench alone at 4am like this dude has
his [__] together that's amazing well I
was up on the top part I look cool
and uh I don't know what it I think it's
the village I don't know a white
privilege who knows what it is but like
a couple of bachelorette parties walk by
and they're all hopped up on estrogen
they're like hey [__] or whatever
and it was the easiest pickup my life
and I had I had to be like I'm fighting
with my wife and they're all like oh why
you guys fighting they're stroking my
leg and [__] I'm like oh my God so I
went back and we worked it all out we've
never been better
in the relationship damn I want it's
like a reset it's a reset yeah and uh I
think that's where the TWA thing came in
because she was like I got to do more
things for him do you know all that [__]
which is like yeah
I don't really know her that well but
you know uh it was a very nice gesture
but um set them in the city so then she
was out of town I went and got flowers I
put him in a Vaz and then she came home
to that I put a little note with all
this [__] so we're back baby but it
sometimes it takes a real clean slate to
start fresh yeah I guess sometimes when
you're just holding [__] in it's
relationships are so tough man yeah I
told him it was like Godfather when
they're like you know every 10 years or
so we have to have a blood bath just to
clear the air exactly and I was like
even though we don't need the family War
we do it yeah yeah the makeup sex was
wild and raunchy and long and nasty I
count I was like wow we did six
positions that's pretty good for a
married couple yeah only three rooms
to a room yeah so uh very good but also
just tip for the men out there ditch
your friends get a cocktail in a
Starbucks cup sit on a bench on the top
you're home free it's your spot that's
pretty good that's the weird thing where
you have to like catch up just so you're
not a creep what do you mean with
alcohol you're like [__] bartender five
shots you just down them all you're like
all right perfect right right let's get
out of here now it's illegal right I
thought saying fighting with my wife
would you know push brush him off a
little but they were like oh about what
now now they're gonna know more about me
that actually helps you're not
threatening now you're a woman has
already chosen you I guess so I told one
girl I was gay and she was like oh I
could flip you or whatever and I was
like damn this is [__] this is a fish
in a barrel here well we had a friend we
knew a guy who was like very gay but he
[__] women and uh yeah I mean he was
like he was like clearly gay but he was
like the biggest [__] block oh yeah like
on a level where you're like dude what
are you are you even enjoying ruining my
night you're more [__] breath
[Applause]
but yeah it was mud oh dude he would
swoop in and like hug them and they'd be
like oh and then he'd like kiss their
cheek before you know what he's making
out with them and you're like I was
talking to her I know I know and you
think well I'm not threatened he's super
gay I'm fine but then he would
slip in
speaking of I gotta peeve it was not
Andy Dick no okay he looks funny
all right I uh
I had a guy say to me the other night he
goes uh so I saw you uh I saw you the
night on the street and say hi because
you were on a date but you were you know
look at an ice cream cone looking like a
homo
hmm that's quite for number one uh I was
on a date with a woman number two uh you
know how homophobic are you that you
have deprived yourself ice cream because
it's gas and number three it was sorbet
so he would think I was even gayer but
but it's so funny to me that you're like
you're that homophobic that you're like
you can't have dessert yeah like the
dude who's just out to dinner and
they're like we have a lovely Tiramisu
and he's like nice try bud
I'm not biting yeah
wow man you had to Zing you somehow
because like you're obviously doing well
you've got a hot lady here with you he
had to get in somewhere with the ice
cream cone I guess was it it's just a
funny it's like it's like a 60s insult
or something we were like ice cream I
can't have ice cream my buddy he's uh
he's a black guy and you know black guys
are very Macho and he my friend was
eating a banana and he was like I had to
throw away the banana because I was
walking down the street and I couldn't
have another black guy I see me the
banana and I was like man that's
hilarious that sucks I eat bananas all
the time but I've never worried like oh
you know I'm a big gay out here I think
they're the number one purchase thing at
Walmart is bananas really oh yeah people
[__] love bananas I love bananas
they're they're a quarter on the
the
yeah I get them every day you know the
number one mover of orange juice is the
Waffle House they sell more orange juice
than anyone else in the country that
makes sense like more than Walmart and
by the way orange is horrible for you
it's all it's it's same amount as a
Coca-Cola but as a kid that we thought
it was healthy you thought it was
healthy they pitched this healthy fruit
drink all you have to do is pitch some
things I mean like think about it like
kind bars like it's like drizzled in
chocolate yes yes I'll be healthy they
have a kind bar they got sued by the way
somebody sued them they're like this is
not healthy at all I did all the numbers
and they they won
yeah it's pretty uh it is funny to me
that like
eating an ice cream cone is like I feel
like sweets you're like called Gay and
you're licking it too which is that's
what you do the [__] you don't really
lick it I guess you could lick the tip
of a dick but you lick a [__] you don't
lick a you got a point they should make
[__] flavored ice cream now you're not
good now you're going out of business
well they got a breast milk you know
they got a couple other how about [__]
yeah I feel like it'd be like a gourmet
Place yeah Gwyneth Paltrow's got a
vagina candle oh
very get on it yeah they call it stink
Berry
steak Berry and then put a cherry on top
now you're popping cherries all right
we're having too much fun that's uh yeah
I don't know if it's a good flavor for
ice cream but I'd be curious yeah I've
tried weird they make they made the mac
and cheese that's true they got all
kinds of weird flavors but if it's [__]
flavored you find a hair in it that
makes sense
now we got some we got a pube yeah I
would say Brazilian restaurants should
have no pubes in it okay it's like a
Brazilian steakhouse all right tweet it
I love those love those Steakhouse oh
you flip the thing over for more meat
it's just the most Savage that's what I
picture this guy eating who called me
that yeah like that's all he eats his
steak right never has any treats ever
but yeah I know there's Brazilian
steakhouses or like [__] dude when they
pull over it's a garlic steak
rib eye like the chicken hearts those
are that's the one where I'm like that's
a little we're eating little hearts yeah
that's how it's like the hands of a
dwarf
but yeah you flip the thing over gay bar
should have that like hey I'll flip this
over I'm ready for another another
sausage you know bring it on I'm ready
I'm not full yet but yeah uh that's
crazy that's a that's a good peeve you
feel like [__] though after those
Steakhouse I did it before a show in
Pittsburgh it was me JP McDade and James
Webb and we that was the only thing open
it was like right after
you know downtowns were kind of hit hard
after covert oh yeah we were playing uh
Pittsburgh improv and was like [__] it
let's go to a steakhouse and dude when I
tell you we had like the meat sweats on
stage it's like you feel like [__] you
feel Dumber you feel Dumber yeah you
feel heavy slow but you can't stop
eating it if somebody has a sword at
your table and he's like got a a [__]
Pitchfork you just gotta say I'll take
it I'll take Wednesday when's the next
time I see a chicken heart I know you
gotta
here's a p for you and this is a nice
guy I hope he never hears this because
it's just it's a little annoying thing
he does this is the hardest one is doing
the peas for the people you know yeah
you might listen
sweet guy
uh we're all hanging out he's not a
comic so it's already a little weird
because he's there no offense but uh
he's all and he's in a group of comics
we're all busting balls telling jokes
laughing telling crazy stories and he
was chiming in he would go that's funny
you say that like if you go uh I went to
a Brazilian steakhouse funniest say that
my buddy's Brazilian and he would tell
his long story about his buddy and
you're like it's not the greatest story
but he has that perfect way in because
he goes that's funny you say that and
you're like no no like without every
time he said it's funny you say it I go
don't do it don't do it we don't want
the story my mom was eating a Pop-Tart
funny you say that you know uh Pop Tarts
are made in in Ohio I knew a guy from
Ohio once you're like God it's almost
impressive the way he could
topscotch over to a thing that he knows
about
the guy with the perfect end yes but
never has an out no way no out I hate
those guys no no it's I I've I've had a
guy like that once we're like they'll
just hit you with like they make they'll
interrupt a conversation you're having
with like small talk yes we're having
like a meaningful conversation to jump
in they're like hey it's hot today right
I was having like a serious conversation
here but I think in his mind he's like I
don't be rude and sit here quietly I'll
join in these guys want me to join in
we're like we don't want you to join in
you could laugh and sit there quietly we
would have no problems with that but
we'll just be more selective yeah it's
tough that's a tough and a nice guy but
the stories they just went nowhere
never-ending stories are tough it's
funny you say that there's a movie
called I saw in the theater in 1981 and
he's like
it is a it is an annoying
it's a great end though funny you say
that and because you're gonna go oh what
what what's funny about it and then here
we are nothing funny about it nothing
and he got us every time and it's a
little rude to say it's funny you say
that because it's not funny it's not
funny I say that we're not laughing
no funny the you lose the edit Button as
you get older too yeah with the stories
oh damn yeah yeah it's it can get tough
yeah it was tough and he's also one of
these guys and he makes where he's from
his whole personality you know he's from
Boston so he's like you know from Boston
so uh and he's got the thick accent and
he's like I'm from Boston so you know we
would uh we would really drink hot I'm
like we all drank hard well we all had a
I drink hard every night I got a podcast
about drinking like you can't just bring
it all back to Boston you know or like
you know I'm from uh San Francisco so I
know about Seafood you're like I know
about Seafood too
no one cares where you're from and you
no we care where you're from but you
can't just make it up your whole world
yeah [__] you're a New York guy but
you're not like so let me just tell you
about the subway yeah let me explain
Pizza to you yes yes we've had pizza
you're Brooklyn you know you know how
many people make Brooklyn their whole
thing yeah I'm from Brooklyn Brooklyn
what what all this [__] you're like all
right just talk to me yeah you've never
brought up Brooklyn no I don't bring it
up I love that
funny thing uh do you actually hate it
more when people are like
that's funny I hate that oh when you say
something's actually funny and they're
like oh it's literally like if you were
[__] someone they were like I'm
coming it's the same energy it's the
worst it's like you laugh you do a yeah
the one where you're like they're like
hmm yeah yeah you're like what what are
you doing send me a text Todd instead
that's 18 insulting yeah it's for like
kind of like in a text it's for like oh
that's weird yeah yeah it's not for a
joke yeah yeah yeah and I think with
Comics it's a little different like
you'll be like is this anything I'm like
oh that's funny yeah
yeah because you want the laugh from the
person
Comics do that I also I'm thinking about
the guy you're telling these the story
to comedians are the worst listeners on
The Planet podcast now because we were
the worst I used to say like the only
time comedians ask about another person
is doing crowd work because we don't do
that I mean we don't ask about people
there we go both you
but uh
no we're just terrible [__] listeners
so if you if you don't edit your stories
properly and have an out we're sitting
there like dude come on we're I know and
especially if you're gonna take the
floor all right we're giving you the
floor here you better you better uh
deliver you know and and I had to tell
them after the 12th story I was like no
more stories I just said too many
stories not another story and he was
like I know I know I tell a lot of them
what's funny about that is
he would literally be like oh we got so
drunk this guy puked everywhere and that
was like the big button you're like but
we don't know those people I don't care
that they puke I've seen puke everybody
pukes I don't know you had to be there
long stories yeah so terrible yeah crazy
I hate other peeps let me see what I
wrote down but let me just say this I've
started my theater tour we did my first
two theaters and it's a it's a Dream
well I did Milwaukee you know it's this
beautiful theater ornate sold out which
one do you do uh perhaps that's
Legendary Legendary fonzi's outside a
big gold Fonzie he's right on the river
great City too never saw it in the
summer either yeah it's like seeing a
woman with makeup you're like damn you
clean up nice I've only seen you you
know in the the pajamas and the the bags
but uh great theater and we had a great
time they gave me a tour manager because
it's without back so I've never had a
tour manager so that's weird so he's
like hey it's funny they think you're
like a special needs person I'm at the
hotel at three I'm like I'm gonna get a
nap in do a little writing maybe take a
[__] and he's like shows at eight we'll
get a runner over there at 6 45 we'll
drop you off you'll be here at seven and
I said hold on
Google it theaters at an 11 minute walk
I said I'll walk it I'll see you there I
always walk it yeah and he's like whoa
six are you gonna walk it you sure what
if you get mugged or kidnapped I'm like
so what do you think I did before you
existed you know like what are we doing
here so I walked over there I got there
like 6 53 he was like Jesus Christ what
the hell and you're like don't worry man
they're used to high maintenance people
yeah and we're pretty easy also they
forget how many years we did in the
clubs right well it was just just sheer
incompetence like some of the clubs are
great but then the other you play a bad
Club oh I mean they'll just forget you
at the airport yes yes they're just like
you didn't send anyone how many times
you showed up at the club and you're
like hey I'm the headliner they're like
well we don't know you and you're like
I'm the guy on the oh I don't know that
uh you went to a club and they're like
can you do the bathroom oh yeah yeah
that was actually in a in a bit yeah
true story I was in a club uh in Myrtle
Beach and uh the woman was like uh can
you can you do the uh urinal cakes in
the bathroom uh and I was like I'm the
comedian she goes so no
not even I'm sorry that's gold she was
like so am like yeah no it's a no uh
yeah no true story I was like my face is
on the poster yeah that's great she was
uh they didn't really respect comedians
there no they sometimes they never do I
remember trying to get paid they were
like oh just wait right here we'll come
get you and I had to it was like two in
the morning I had to knock on the door
and they're like crunching numbers in
there with a bunch of receipts and
waitresses are all waiting to get paid I
had to wait to get paid to like three in
the morning and then I had a flight at
like seven brutal happened to me at Fort
Myers same same thing yeah there you go
you just like let me get like three
hours of sleep I know and they're just
they just have you waiting and you're
like is anyone coming yeah you're like
I'm the show on your show and you're
scared to leave yes because I've been
stiff before exactly so you're like let
me just get a check cause even if it
bounces at least I have some paper right
right I'm like so [__] stupid the
waiter is gonna be here tomorrow I'm
never coming back so pay me first how
about that but yeah so uh it was just so
weird and he's like you want food I'm
like oh we get food he's like we'll get
whatever you want we'll send a runner
out I'm like a runner I still I still
don't think the New York clubs pay
properly to comedians what do you mean I
just don't think the New York club is
paid properly like if you headline or if
you no just uh like spot pad I think it
has been raised and like it's been
raised like ten dollars in 30 years yeah
yeah it's crazy it's a little weird when
you played rogans and it was diesel
right that's crazy pay comedian
he's a zillionaire and yeah and he's but
seriously making the same amount that
the seller's making in a night right
right but Rogan essentially opened a
non-profit because he doesn't he just
wants to make a good club exactly okay
which is unheard of
um so yeah uh great but these clubs are
all making good money and like it
doesn't affect guys like Mark and myself
at this point as much but if you're a
younger comic
that's you're living in a [__] day
job yeah yeah or or you know you're on
the road Harbor a lot of those guys
aren't on the road yet the club should
all be paying more yeah yeah I never
thought about that they really should in
New York all of them I got the best
company I ever got this guy's like I'm
doing
um also the tour manager for this group
that group that group and he he's like I
just want to go with you because it's so
easy with a comedian I show up I go
sounds good okay I just talk on the mic
for two seconds and then I go how about
we get Thai food I feed everybody and
then we go home it's the best also I'll
do one better I don't even do a sound
check I don't either
well he does he knows what I like he
does it you know yeah you know how I
talk there's always talk on stage yeah
but uh can you hear me great we got it
did you do and also veterz on before me
usually and Gary's so low energy that
I'm like if the mugs [__] up for him
I'll be fine we'll figure it out right
right what uh you did Milwaukee and Iowa
Milwaukee and Des Moines Milwaukee
Friday one show Des Moines one show on
Saturday and went home on Sunday it was
amazing that's nice a nice weekend how
is Iowa oh dude I was underrated it's
just Des Moines is a badass City it's
clean everybody's so friendly it's some
of the best looking fat people in
America and everything's fried and it's
all it's like County Fair and corn and
fun and just uh beer a lot of beer there
it's just a great time and I walked I
walked to the gig and people were
honking are like I'm going to see right
right it just feels like lighter there
feels like there's no Jonah Hill drama
no one's worried about lizzo they're
just having fun living life and doing
Fentanyl
no one's worried about lizzo they're
just eating until they look like it yeah
exactly but white lizzo is out there
yeah actually I've been on the road in a
minute because it's like a first stretch
uh oh does he want to come in oh hey all
right popping well what is this Seinfeld
is Kramer's gonna slide in all right
tell them all right sorry I'm uh I'm not
on my phone because I'm a professional
but tell them to pop all right
all right but yeah where were you this
weekend I was here is it doing Cellar
spots and it's it's great I mean it's
fun to be home but it is it is hard to
work on stuff it's hard because you're
following some new people who are just
killer like some of their stuff is
they're just going Bam Bam Bam and then
you go up your first few minutes you
gotta kill and then
they always let you early on the weekend
they always do it's like 15 turns into
like 12 and you're like it's it's hard
to get work done I know and it's a
weekend so you kind of feel weird being
like let me try this brand new idea and
I'll work it out because they're like
they're drunk and it's date night and
they're they want to see a show I don't
know I feel weird working out on a
Tuesday feels a lot better for me
weekends are overrated I agree I think
everything is better yes yes and the
streets in New York especially in the
village on a weekend it's like a lot
it's a lot well yeah well so Vince and I
went up we started [__] around a
little bit and Estes in the crowd
watching us I'm like well now we're not
gonna go hard of course we're not gonna
we're not like how hard do you think
we're gonna push the limits here yeah
when when the Booker's watching us
that's so backwards that the booker of
the club makes you less funny
isn't that weird like something about it
makes you more intimidated and you can't
be yourself and you can't be loose
there's there needs to be more
experimentation there's this expectation
the comedy seller to kill and I think
it's like killing's great but
when you're doing three shows a night
you think I'm gonna do the same set I
know I know no it's like I want to
explore a little bit Colin Quinn used to
always say like you clubs are architect
I'm not talking about the seller the
seller's great but clubs in general are
architects of their own destruction when
they don't let comedians explore like
that's the process should be a little
ugly occasionally like yeah if I kill
for 12 out of 15 minutes those three
minutes were new bits and they'll get
there you know exactly but uh yeah so I
don't like weekends there's like a weird
expectation to
Sunday's like looser you can kind of
figure it out yeah it totally agree and
also people like ah the road I hate the
road I'm miserable I'm like I love the
road I love the hotel I mean the flight
sucks and all that but like what
happened okay you just feel so unhealthy
uh
though I mean it's the fun I mean the
way you're doing the road now is good
and that's like luckily I was doing
theaters this year too and it was it was
easier but it is you realize how
unhealthy the road is when you spend
like a week straight in New York that's
true holy [__] I feel good that's true
yeah isn't that crazy that's a good
point but yeah
[Music]
come in yeah do a little pop-up you know
the seat that's here we go don't lie
you've probably been using your manscape
ball shaver on that face so it's time to
pick up that beard hedger guilty I've
done it guilty it's a cordless trimmer
with a rotary wheel that gives you 20
different hair cutting lengths with one
guard no more messy drawers full of
extra ads on add-ons I use this I'm
literally I have a beard I don't like
being clean shaven uh I look like a boy
not a fan manscape is great
Kevin Spacey loves me when I walk that
way but I don't want to see him anymore
this baby has a long last battery
Universal charging and a strong motor
that will get you the look you want if
you're a clean-shaven kind of guy the
handyman is your ticket for a smooth
stubble free look whether you've got
that five o'clock shadow or you're
working on the Jack Sparrow situation
manscaped has the tools for you twenty
percent off free shipping with the code
drunk at manscape.com that's 20 off with
free shipping at manscape.com use code
drunk hit that refresh button with
manscapes oh yeah
hey folks we might be drunk as brought
to you by fume when you're trying to
quit a bad habit it can be a tough
Journey your brain freaks out your body
craves what it used to it's a lot to
handle fume has you covered this
Innovative device uses flavored Air
instead of vapor and dangerous chemicals
so you can keep the Habit you love
without the harm love fume it's a cute
little doohickey I love to suck on it
put it in my mouth it's great they know
what they're doing and everybody says
it's the oral fixation that's what gets
you so this covers that you're good and
it's healthier feeling angsty fume
thought you might be with movable parts
and magnets for fidgeting keep your
hands and brain occupied while you
transition to a better habit stop oh
stopping is something we all put off
because it's hard but switching to fume
is easy enjoyable and fun fume is over
served over 100 000 customers and has
thousands of success stories and there's
no reason that can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanity breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
journey pack today head to
trifum.com and use code drunk to save a
whole 10 percent nice when you get the
journey pack today that's
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use code drunk to
save an additional 10 off your order
today tryfume.com
code drunk the NFL is back baby time for
tailgating pain in your face and getting
some action go G-Man DraftKings in a
special sorry DraftKings an official
sports betting partner of the NFL has
given you a campus offer for week one
new customers can get 200 bucks and
bonus bets instantly when you bet just
five bucks in any any NFL game all
customers can snag two new offers every
single game day this September so
download the app and see what you get
download now and use code wmbd to sign
up new customers can take home 200 in
bonus bets instantly just for betting
five dollars that's code wmbd only on
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL the crown is
yours gambling problem call 1-800
Gambler or visit
www.1800 gambler.net in New York call
8778 Hope NY or text Hope NY in
Connecticut help is available for the
problem of gambling also if you're in
Connecticut help is available call 8
eight eight seven eight nine seven seven
or visit
ccpg.org please play responsively on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino and Resort
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction void
in Ontario c c d k n g dot Co slash
football for eligibility terms and
responsible gambling resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility and deposit restrictions
apply cut that part all right by the way
can we can we get a beard you a CPAP
machine geez I heard you breathing from
a mile away there I think we had to cut
your mic
all right yank that arm over hey silk
he's gonna get those cookies
you whoop two down I know I had two this
morning too I got a problem what are you
in uh the studio for it sounds like
we're in prison what are you in for uh
I'm doing my my hit podcast mindful
Metal Jacket oh nice and Ari's coming in
oh nice yeah Jesus
all right it's better than the
construction you played 400 times oh my
God speaking of cookies you know what
gets me is they I go to that lounge and
I have to take seven cookies I have to
take them in a Delta Lounge yeah really
it's like a pile of chocolate chip and
now they've upgraded to Rice Krispie
treats yeah I don't their cookies aren't
great though the 7-Eleven cookies were
better than the Delta Lounge cookies
well it's not the best cookie it's no uh
what is it Aunt Patty what's that lady
that's a pretzel pretzel I don't know
enough Mrs field yeah that guy knows his
cookie the old pedophile there he's
putting them out for the kids well
something I've talked about with these
Delta lounges that bothers me is they
don't
factor in account for they don't account
for just white trash garbage people who
fly a lot that's true like they you go
in there and they have salmon drizzled
with honey quinoa give me a hot dog and
some mac and cheese well I've never
heard a complaint about healthy food I
love that about it no that's because you
come from some class I'm a dog [__] I
grew up in the woods like an [__] I
want a slice of cheese that's what I
hate when you when your only options are
trash you feel like [__] at the club you
get to the club it's only chicken wings
and pizza that's why they do a little of
both they understand everything that's
why I'm coming out with cookies because
the the trash in me I'm like they're
falling out of my pockets you know I'm
like a like a bandit I like the healthy
option but just also have like school
lunch where I went to school anyways
cheese pizza was always on the menu
right whatever lunch today is salami
sausage or whatever yeah cheese pizza
was there if you needed it it's a good
one it's sitting on those heat lamps I
remember we had a square piece no I
remember that yeah we had Square too I
know I was a big Bagel guy we did a lot
of bagels toasting Bagels a little tough
yeah you look fantastic what'd you get a
haircut what the hell is happening here
you look well kept you look good yeah
you look good all right thanks you look
good I've been exercising I'm trying to
take care of myself in the city this
weekend so you can kind of decompress oh
my God it's like the first time I don't
feel like I'm yeah I was just saying the
road you don't realize how unhealthy it
is to you're actually here for a few
days and you're like holy [__] can I say
that I hate to sound like a contrarian I
feel like I'm healthier on the road
really yeah because
in ways because on the road it's like
it's just me I mean I have a buddy there
but I'm like I wake up and there's less
to do less to do let me let me go to the
gym the gym is just right there you're
not doing podcasts on the road right
like here I'm like I'm running for
podcast to podcast or there's a meet up
or a hang or whatever or you're just
like I'm finally home let me just order
some delivery whatever um I mean the
diet is bad yeah just on the road I
guess we're semi-healthy we try to hoop
and stuff but it's just I need a drink
drink yeah I need a drink after the
shows and it turns in I'm I don't need a
drink yeah I do
take it one day at a time it I'm less
tempted to drink in the city weirdly I'm
just like I can just go home I can go
home yeah yeah you're not they don't
have that hotel sadness on the road
doing at home but then I sleep better on
the road for sure that [__] drilling
you saw I think mentally I'm better on
the road because there's no this is
outside this is this is my apartment
every day
crazy huh oh my God I know sounds like
when I leave my wife at home alone
you'll get better A lot of vibrating
should I sleep better on the road but
that's insanity but also the city on the
road usually it's a nicer play the
city's a train ride it's horrible it's a
toilet it's just I I mean it's elevated
train it's homeless it's traffic it's
horns honking yeah the small the small
space the small apartment and then with
the hotel you can jizz everywhere you
don't have to clean it you know you can
really make a mess out of it yeah you
can eat it
whatever it is Mark are you still
stealing from the airport uh you know
places where you buy food I do a little
for sport now before I was like oh my
God I need these two disgusting
hard-boiled eggs that are when a weird
liquid or or I need this kind bar bring
hard-boiled eggs from the lounge on the
flight that's disgusting well I eat them
in the line I don't eat them on the
plane I'm not an animal but I'm saying I
go to Hudson News and I'll
really a sticky finger or maybe like an
Inquirer or something
yeah I get it all right it's very
overpriced it's outrageous and uh you
know you buy the two things and then one
is for you how much longer are you do
you think they'll sell magazines at a
at an airport I think I think that's the
only place to sell maggots that's my
point how much how long do you think
they have
I mean newspapers are pretty much they
feel almost gone yeah that's true yeah
newspapers that was a big part of life
that printing yeah you know extra extra
when I was a kid my mom would Circle
that's what the kids say extra extra
Read All About It remember that oh yeah
extra it is actually they made a New
York accent yeah New York accent oh I
don't pull it up I don't know extra oh
yeah but my mom would Circle garage
sales in the classifieds and that was
our big Sunday I would go with her so
that trash is deep well I remember I was
follow the Home Run Chase with Griffey
when I was a kid reading a box score
yeah and every morning I would go and
the way I would know if somebody homered
was the
great timing with these sounds
like extra he's saying extra it says
extra hold on I gotta hear extreme
you were saying Ken Griffey Jr oh but
you would go and if he had if there was
a one hit one run scored One RBI you're
like I bet he Homer then you would go to
the bottom to see a home run right yeah
and uh it was exciting I mean you feel
it it feels like we're from the 30s it's
the best but you'd scan through there
for the Box Jordan scored oh the sports
page was it was a big thing not only
that but I remember reading like the box
office for movies that was like a big
thing I was just curious I'm not Jewish
but still
I didn't need to know how much money the
movie made but yeah I was curious oh I
would look up the times yeah the times
was big I wanted to know what was making
money I was curious
yeah I didn't know you're going with the
uh what they brought in the rake uh
I was scared you never did that I did I
also used to look up what TV show is the
top 10 TV shows yeah I was curious okay
that was a big thing it'd be like
Frasier Seinfeld yeah yeah it was kind
of cool that was fun they gave you a
little blurb too Frazier gets in hot
water with Roz or whatever you know they
give you a little nugget but they don't
do that anymore we don't know what
ratings are by the way have you read
your description for Netflix I hated it
it's not what do you say it's like
raunchy uh or you take comments on his
wife's stomach or something what it says
ripping one in front of a loved one and
I was like oh did you write that no of
course not you can get them to run that
passage it says Mark Norman touches on
topics such as ripping one in front of
them awkward lap dancing that's the
intimacy of letting one rip in front of
a spouse comedian Mark Norman rapid fire
Specialists
they sent me a bad one I think that I
don't know what they say about me but
they I turned it down because it was
something like they were like I think
they opened with Sam Morel talks about
porn and I was like I talk about other
[__] one joke I mean I'm grateful for
Netflix I love Netflix but just write
like one of the best comedians [__]
killer hour watch it there you go that's
it it's some queef out there they got it
the copywriting like a like a 19 year
old girl who's who's head of the social
media probably wrote that well ai's
gonna take over all of us and kill us
hey I could have done better
but yeah yeah those blurbs are brutal I
mean Netflix they're so nervous like
that's pretty clean of a blurb you know
like I I made a trailer and I sent it to
them they're like we're not sure if our
audience is gonna get this and I'm like
so my audience will but your audience
won't get it like what does that mean
and then I kept pushing back and
eventually they go all right well you
say God damn in the trailer I was like
I'll take it out but just tell me that
we went through 12 laps of [__] to
get to that yeah it's like a beginning
of a relationship what do you mean well
they just won't tell you how they really
feel oh it's like pull it out of them no
it's [__] annoying but we could yeah
could have taken the goddamn out we
would have been on our way in one email
it's like when I did Letterman and uh
they were like they we want you to do
your McDonald's chunk and I was like can
I just trash McDonald's on Letterman
they're like yeah we love it and then
like six months of sending them tapes
getting the jokes right literally six
months they're like ah McDonald's is a
sponsor we can't make fun I told you
that yeah what is that and no one gets
fired by the way well they're all fired
now the show doesn't
you know I'm terrified no it's wordy but
uh it doesn't work on a hilariously
unfiltered journey into the absurdities
of Modern Life that's way better way
better already oh this is horrifying to
sex relationships technology complexity
of being an almost adult in this
uproariously uh net in his uproarious
Netflix special it's tragic all right
[__] it this is so much better let's
just replace all accused with Chad gbt I
feel like he's not
[Laughter]
you're done no that's it is amazing
we'll just put a Hawaiian shirt on a
laptop and it's it's a whole it's a
better you should do the skeleton like a
Craig Ferguson remember that yeah yeah
there you go there it is that's Sally
you're gone
anal Intruder that I remember when I did
America's Got Talent they were trying to
it's weird when they try to get involved
in your set where you're like you're not
comedians I remember they they were like
do this phone joke you have I'm like
it's not gonna work I got a promise it's
like too offensive for your crowd yeah
they were like it's our favorite joke
and I'm like I'm not they would pushed
me to do and finally I was like No And I
got eliminated they're probably right
but you know but they we know our act we
know what does well where and how and
who and why I know my alleys hey what's
that shirt oh Kenny Powers Eastbound and
Down oh now watch that man I watched it
oh my God you never watched it it's one
of the funniest shows ever I know I suck
I said talk to me last night I thought
it was fantastic what is that it's
Australian horror movie that's uh it's
it's like made it here any type of
foreign film makes it here you know it's
pretty good true it's true but Ronan
hated it we got in like a shouting match
in the hallway he hates everything scary
I don't love scary movies I like a
horror movie he hated it it's pretty fun
but if you haven't seen it I don't know
what we're doing is it was it like a
hereditary where you're like oh God or
is it a silly goofball no that's what I
thought which I like bowls but um well
first of all it's 90 minutes good run
time yeah I love a 90 minute movie yeah
we gotta do it Woody uh it's a it's like
a it's almost like a Ouija board it's
like this hand I keep calling it talk to
the hand but you hold on to the hand and
you say let me in and it takes you to
the spirit world but it's like an
allegory for drugs the kids are all
doing it there's a lot of layers like
they're all tick-tocking it and they're
kind of not concerned and then they they
have they get all [__] up and crazy
but then afterwards they're like let's
do it again so it's like sort of
allegorical but also there's like
parental relations and friendships and
all this stuff and it gets quite [__]
gory and crazy and it's really I thought
it was damn good great premise yeah I
love it I love when they're putting Tick
Tock and I like I hate Tick Tock but
they're putting in movies because it
does exist it's weird when there's no
phones or anything in a movie I'm like
it's 20 23. no phones in this yeah it's
very straight there's no one sitting
looking at a phone that would be half of
a movie if you were being realistic
there's all these articles now saying
that people forgot how to behave in
movies did you see these like like
Barbie Oppenheimer people are behaving
like drunken [__] and it's like you
realize there's like probably a
generation of people going to these now
who just have never really gone to the
movies did you notice that not when I
went but yeah we had uh Luke bonus who's
a nut just hilarious funny guy yeah he
was like we were a group of kids came
and they were kind of chatting and uh I
might have to run my guess for my
podcast might be showing up oh yeah yeah
you got Ari's number yeah yeah shoot him
a text would you
oh perfect hey this guy's on it
um so anyways we go there and it's like
it's crowded and a group of teenagers
show up and they're chatting like as the
lights are coming down it's getting
ready and I say to Luke just so you know
like I am not above making a scene at a
movie theater and he was like oh me
either it was like Kramer and so then it
comes like the Universal Studios logo
comes on and he just goes
oh I would have I wait until we're into
the picture sure I've given them the
benefit of the doubt and he does the big
shush and they were like it was this is
in uh San Jose they're like Indian kids
so they were like oh like shocked they
weren't like hey [__] you yeah yes they
were like Jesus Christ and so they start
whispering
this is a great scene
AI wouldn't have pulled that up you're
back you're back in
the popcorn spilled
I think they get lower and lower that's
Michelle Pfeiffer's sister that's right
that guy is great
[Music]
because I would love it
incredible incredible but so he shushed
him and then like a couple minutes later
there's like the tiniest and he's like
wow again and then like a few minutes
later the tiniest wimpery and he goes
that's it and I was like you gotta stop
because at some point there's an adverse
effect yes yes because if you turn start
yelling now we're missing all of this
now our heart rate Spike now they're mad
now we're like fighting they're behind
us they're gonna throw sodas at us and
at some point you're like I would rather
block out two people like I like this
movie yeah then have to deal with we're
in like a weird fist fight thing yeah
now you're missing the whole movie yes
so you're right it's completely
overblown like this during the movie yes
that was crazy I have something that
works nine out of ten times it's very
simple I just turn around and say you
know I can hear every word you guys are
saying
because you think you think you're like
I'm keeping it to ourselves yeah but
it's like I can hear everywhere and then
it stops it almost immediately wow
that's good because then they're also
like I don't want him to hear what I'm
saying exactly that's good you got to
respect people at the movie theater
remember I was on a date with a girl
once and she takes the phone out we're
at the film form which is like a oh yeah
you don't take the phone out
what during trailer during the movie
[__] that and just to answer a text yeah
and I see uh what all the problem is out
of control in this city I'll tell you
that right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's just too hot out man sun's out guns
out it is cloudy though so I have no
excuse three degrees Yeah I'm sorry
what's going on bikes up here it's humid
do you get it do you fish with a stick
is there a bag on the end of that stick
are you right
she's looking for friends you do look
like the second guy in command behind
Moses in the desert right now I'm here
if you need me Moses
did you hear America is getting rid of
GPS for the world huh what Trump put it
in a play he's like why are you paying
for it everybody else should pay for it
wait what yeah we've been paying for GPS
oh because they're the whole world our
GPS yeah interesting yeah Trump movie
chat GPS is correct yeah
all right when you work did you check
the box office in the newspaper for
movies that came out where you're like
let me see who's winning the box office
oh yeah oh wow that was a very
anti-semitic experiment you just did Joe
well I'm very interested in money too
obviously but media I've heard a lot
worse anti-semitic experiments
but yeah
it's called Eugenics what are you guys
doing what are you just talking about
today well we had no guess and list
popped in and then you popped in so we
have two surprise guests on this one
there you go it's two going to Jew there
we go right now the comment start should
have been nobody no I think these are
these are no this is yeah what what do
you think you and I could beat these two
at basketball they probably got it I got
it we got you always a Lockdown Defender
too we can take a pickle pickleball easy
oh yeah you think so we got we got
length yeah we played I played okay I'm
not great though I'm okay yeah we got
you be there well cornhole I think would
dominate no Cornell I'm great bowling
I'm great oh you got can you guys Bowl I
can bowl you can't bowl with your back I
can't Bowl you can do one yo you can
bring out that cart where you push it
and let it
[Music]
we'll beat you in pickleball Mark will
be a [__] that's wrong you would look
at your abs in the window while we're
dropping shots my shirt on I'm like
Chrysler over here oh that's crazy
pickleball will smoke it we should film
it yes now we're off on a time really
but wait a minute but then we get
basketball I don't yeah we got
basketball how's your back for
basketball I'm good dude I haven't been
hurting in weeks I'll I'll bomb in
basketball I just saw white man can't
jump I could pick great oh the new one
no the old one the Old One's great oh
but it's got a few flaws in it it's so
funny I just watched it recently so they
got to get the duck and whatever they're
playing the duck King of the duck
they're playing for 2500 a game that's
just what he lost when in the [__]
thing he now he can get a house to 2500
but before for 5 000 he couldn't okay oh
this should have been a 25 000 buy-in
for the duck in the king the the wife
Rosie Perez or the girlfriend is happens
to be working on foods with the letter q
and that's in this in the game that's
pretty wild
my thing we talked about recently that's
not a joke it happens that's the end of
the movie another one that we talked
about on our podcast recently was that
they get kicked out the snookies chase
them out of their hotel and then the
next scene they're in a different hotel
and she has all her posters and maps and
everything she just moved in and they
left all their [__] behind but pull up
her tits in that tank top nice she still
looks kind of good actually oh really
that was early nipple on my life that
was great big nip the stookies and where
do you what are you can kind of play he
wouldn't know they could all they could
all play yeah there were only a couple
shots where I'm like that bounce past
the Hang On that would not have gone
that way yeah they said uh Billy uh
Woody Harrelson was the better player
everybody else's outfit was as gay as
anyone on Broadway today it's bright
purple spandex yeah the little hats they
all dressed like Richard Simmons for
some reason
the other flaw is the portal on the
right side of Sally's [__] here
our milk teachers men over 40. did you
seriously look this up on a porno site
he did yeah have you heard of YouTube
all the the brightness up he knew how to
make some women squirt but he didn't
know how to make any woman squirt and
that's what he was searching for another
thing in this scene is you can see she
has no protection he's like she's fully
nude there with money in her [__] I'm
just watching a black screen here is
this a close-up of Wesley what is this
too much he killed it by the way he
steals that movie he's Charming as [__]
yeah he's great he was amazing then he
stopped doing comedy he's then paying
taxes he was in there he was in the
Eddie Murphy one recently wasn't he
interested in something
the other flaw is they keep trying to
set up the the hustle and they're like
you could pick anybody out here and he's
like I'll take this guy and you're like
the white guy that drove all the way to
watts and carrying a basketball and not
just some old fat guy that I've already
seen play bad it's like it's like no no
forget all these people there's somebody
coming off the subway I'm sure he'll
stop hey I'll stop he's a block away but
it helps Cheryl come play with him he's
a white guy in an all-black neighborhood
carrying a basketball basketball
sneakers of course he's gonna be good
yeah there's some underrated jokes in
there too no no it ain't Raymond I'm
gonna get my other gun shoot everybody's
ass great comedy then yeah cut this
[__] right here
it's amazing that guy is an NBA player
he played he won national championship
at UCLA under one who was it the one
that is
the one that wanted they hustled him I'm
gonna go back in my car get my other gun
shoot everybody's ass I will never bring
you water
yeah yeah that movie was there other are
there any other good basketball movies
besides that Hoosiers is good but like
what's another Joanna man it's not great
Teen Wolf
Diaries was hustled Adam Sandler hustle
is good really good was it was a good
movie yeah what about Blue Chips
he died today wow oh yeah
I love Blue Chips don't step on any of
the kids okay all right yeah yeah a lot
of that was in Louisiana I just love
[__] second greatest role next to Shazam
hey have you not seen steel oh good
point good idea was a [__] that was a
rough one yeah awesome God he's great
and the same guy from white man can't
jump by the way Shaquille O'Neal Shaq
looks like he weighs like 180 here
Nolte's got to be one of the worst
transition from like hot Hollywood guy
to [__] horrible looking now yeah
built it yeah he was a handsome like
Cape Fear Nick because he hung out with
Barbra Streisand for a week and then he
said why just give up he's up there with
Ari
well that that mug shot was a punch line
for like a decade but he was sexiest man
he was he won sexiest man look it up I
bet he did you get in here Beauty and
Nolte I always get it mixed up me too
Salukis is behind on the lookups we
never got Raymond basketball star
oh wow he looks like Letterman I think
one of these people is Gary Busey yeah
yeah the left there we go Bruce he was
amazing and um Point Break Point Break
yeah was he in a submarine movie Utah
get me two that's Gene Hackman
Periscope down or what is that
he doesn't look that bad I thought he
would look worse yeah he's a little
Irish uh yeah he's just red-faced oh
yeah and be a good guest I would love to
have Museum he would drink us under the
table you see wood yeah Syracuse his
outfit
holy [__] that's Nolte oh oh sorry busy
yeah yeah busy be an amazing guest it's
funny that they're both kind of nuts it
seems yeah and they look alike it's
about to Le Boosie all right
went crazy
juicy went crazy Gary Busey went crazy I
think he had a head injury after what
was that movie he played in the 80s it
was amazing he played uh Point Break
Buddy Holly Buddy Holly he had a head
injury from a motorcycle accident kind
of lost his [__]
that's what happens but I heard the guy
who runs the Springfield Club you know I
heard he had a head injury from a crash
because one of the guys when I was there
you go he goes he was a completely
different person before this they say
that with everybody Roseanne was normal
Sam Kinison was normal what do you think
he's doing now giving away percentage
deals
she had a car accident and uh totally
kind of went and became a comedian oh
really became a comedian yeah interested
that's so sick that the comedian has an
origin story
you're a [__] superhero that's true
Jesus look at Pryor he watches mom [__]
a bunch of Johns you know and Peoria
he's Don Draper yeah right
wow so your mother being a prostitute
really leads to some success because
Roberto Durante
Roberto Duran is that his name yeah like
drug addicts and losers and there's
other side of it yeah well thanks for
stepping on the bit right yeah let him
milk it Jesus Christ can we get three
punch lines out you're like actually
so you're saying your mother being a
prostitute not not great no got it got
it write that down
yeah that's when uh what's the guy who
beat him because Durant was like amazing
he called someone else's mom a [__] and
beat the guy who was way better than him
all right I think it was Sugar Ray Four
Kings on Showtime is that where you're
getting this info for Kings I remember
that one it was a new Showtime doc Four
Kings and it's unbelievable no no
Showtime docks are kind of underrated
yeah it's hard to get to but yeah I
watched the Ron Artest one recently it's
[__] great it was just the Kings
then as we were Kings or whenever Kings
black people love being called King they
do and white black women would be called
queen and the ruler they like the ruler
in the rap world I've never heard them
Slick Rick the ruler oh yeah and Lil and
big is Big too little is Big you're
right I used to work at FYE the record
store CD store For Your Entertainment
alphabet yes for what we would
alphabetize it was like all the rap
stickers all else for little and and
Biggs wow it was b l also where do you
uh we're in alphabetical order where do
you put a cash sign as an s
oh good I think that's siness
I would put it before the a it's a
number or is it it's a symbol you're
right it's like Prince
uh any rap stars calling please I know
Ella culture is busy doing his Brock the
bells Festival but if you can take a
break and call him we'd love that do you
have any of the videos I sent in oh
let's pull up a video for us it sounds
like a hacky joke but I was working at
FYE in a guy came and he's like you got
50 Cent and I thought he was I was like
oh I can't help you bro he's like you
don't got 50 Cent
I had never heard of this artist and I
was like I don't know what to tell you
I'm giving you money he pulled out of
20. so you got 50 Cent you're like well
I'm really confused
what do we have what is this dub I don't
know what that one is make it big what's
that trying it's hard all right what's
this
is that Luke Wilson Oh I know what this
is I didn't say this is a guy so if you
can hypnotize what's wrong with you
block punches chat gbt get shot GPT in
here
oh okay okay
so I think this guy's like a energy
Master he says I can block punches oh
wait before you press play I'm gonna
guess he doesn't block I made a [__] on
it here we go
that was no sound so he's saying he can
block punch like a force field
and then put him up against an MMA
fighter oh
that's from his knees wow I feel bad for
this guy he's an idiot he's an idiot
Jake Paul if he went against a real
fighter he had to really believe it yeah
I know but he's not a boxer
so what is this an amazing fight it
happened just yesterday oh with the
folding chair yeah what is the this is
crazy all right so the context basically
is there's a security guard telling this
group of white boaters you can't dock
here you have to move your boat okay
that's all you need okay and then they
and they I saw this they I behave like
[__] lunatics
okay
uh oh you missed the bet there's a
better angle yeah there's a way better
angle on this I'm gonna look for it
standby I said you can't dock here and
they go I'm gonna find a better video
standby but wait wait why did they give
a [__] so bad that they're docking
because they clearly should face and
they're just [__] looking for
trouble yeah
okay
sort of giving it away here hold on I'm
gonna find another one you guys just
talk okay yeah don't give it away since
we're all but I bet it's on
all right can I ask this yes side note
I'm renting a studio and we're cutting
into the time am I losing out of this
thing yeah I would uh take advantage of
that I feel like we might have to go
go put it be a [__] drink while I'm
here as a guest oh yeah grab whatever
you want oh there's no tender you just
have a [__] scotchy Scotch
what are you doing good scotch
11. one of the mats has got to get up
there although I would recommend Peters
because Sally's what's the lack of
balloon 11 is that a novelty one
it's got to be a novelty one no that's
real baby that's a 18 year baby no it's
novelty what do you mean the Offerman
Edition it was a novelty [__] one
[__] him let him die in this 11.
that's a fun sound it's a fun sound that
is I'll try it actually
[Music]
oh or you want to give the man a log of
whatever he wants an orbodega cat which
is still available online
you can get them online now yeah yeah
nice place to get them oh it's literally
Nick Offerman yeah they don't make it
11. for some reason what that is pretty
cool to be on that Edition that really
is Nick Offerman I thought you were
kidding oh no no that's a good joke I
would never say that no he's uh he's a
partner wow
oh damn McKenna this is gripping radio
oh yeah I know right so I derail it by
asking for it [__] no well I trailed
to ask about what's in the box the
studio uh it's two cigars for later some
old Macs for foundation what's in the
box why don't you go to a different
video Matt if this isn't it looks like
you're once you check your email
it looks like you're the you're near the
hobo move where they this one was like
Mad Gold but they knocked the [__] out
of it all right see Alex have you ever
seen this Sam Donald Trump no I haven't
seen it
[Music]
boom boom
but it's your Vladimir young made this
who's Tim young that one comedian
[Laughter]
Simeon the one took over tiggs account
I think so yeah did you see the Tweety
wrote about uh the women's soccer
what it's a doozy I don't want to ruin
it I'm going to Jumble it all up but
it's uh it's comedy let's read it
how's that McKenna 10 year baby it's not
bad
yeah what an [__] that's what you're
supposed to say how's that free 10 year
old scotchy to spell that's okay that's
Kentucky burger right
salad Keys You've Lost Your Touch oh my
God this is brutal no by the way we
still haven't seen Raymond the
basketball player
is that it Mark I believe yeah yeah what
does that say the shocking and totally
unexpected loss by the U.S women's
soccer team to Sweden is fully
emblematic of what is happening to our
once great nation
that's awesome many of our players were
openly hostile to America no other
country behaved in such a manner even
close woke equals failure Nice Shot
Megan
oh they go at it I forgot to go at it
nice shot Megan clearly it's Biden's
fault they lost that's so funny I mean
well he might be right that's they're
only hired women
that's so [__] funny
he loves to rub it in he loves to rub it
in he missed it like a big shot it
ruined the whole game for him yeah
that's great I got something else here
it's a bit of mystery I'm just gonna
play it oh good okay
he's eating crayons just Joe and Ronald
talk movies oh my Lord it is running
[__] oh my God that's emblematic of
what's happening to our country
oh my God that's uh fentanyl
what the [__] is he the [__] was it oh I
sent this one and this one's kind of fun
here we go uses a back on it
[Laughter]
says veterans new half hour special
media yeah that's pretty good no hatred
right just two people dancing talking
about their chai drink so is that what
that was yeah they don't have internet
so they'll never see this
I can't tell if it's fun house or their
or they're small people he's got real
bow leg he's this he's lower than the
car look at that bike is Tower oh good
point good point it looks normal like a
head size is all just look normal
okay oh this is a good one this is a
good one here they really sit up there
and let uh chaotic okay okay
what's your relationship status today
I mean you can see me in my relationship
status man these my Queens these my
beautiful girls right yeah man these are
the girls that hold me down they take
care of me they do everything for me man
they eat my butt all of them they eat my
butt back to back sometimes together
sometimes they take turns they the ones
who make me feel like the king that I am
you understand what I'm saying without
them I wouldn't be nothing for sure I
disagree America's in a great place
yeah well the only way I can know that
you worthy of eating my butt is is by
the way the way you treat me before you
can even be able to eat my butt you
understand what I'm saying you got to
cater to me you gotta you gotta show me
that you willing to sacrifice for me you
gotta show me that you love me that
you're gonna put work in for me
loyal to me that you're gonna be
faithful to me and once you show me all
of these things then I will allow you to
eat my butt that's the only way
this guy's gotta figure this guy's got
it he's not chaotic at all I love that
the interview is really asking the hard
questions too yeah and what does it take
to eat your butt oh man you gotta jump
through hoops to heat someone else's ass
he needs to trust them I can't have
someone I don't trust eating my butt
they might take a bite that's Inner
Circle yeah yeah hey Inner Circle
hey I don't even think that was on
purpose but no it was not I'll take
credit for it though yeah there you go
you're fine you double did something
good what's this
evening
[Applause]
[Music]
.
that is [__] that is some feel-good
content I Gotta Give it something nice
Brad Williams is a Halloween cup
that is uh
did you see the dock they did the dock
on Hulk Hogan versus Gawker no it's
[__] he destroyed Goku destroyed it
he won 15. who did somebody back him
Peter Thiel because he was like I hate
Gawker so I'll just give you all the
money you need for your defense
and he was like [__] you I'll destroy
you when I get a chance and he was like
I got a horse to back now and he backed
Hulk wow it was like 140 million and
they're like we don't have that [__]
money
if you do yeah wow and so get out of
business I used to love The Gawker blind
items where it was just a rumor
and once it was like Louie is dating a
comedian and everyone thought it was
Michelle wolf you started that I didn't
start it I was making fun of her at the
cellar but uh red hair yeah and it was
like not at all
he's got a big mop of red hair that's
one of the best lines ever in curb uh
what's it Cheryl's dad let me watch that
Karen top the other day he's funny he's
got a big mop of red hair
that's such a perfect thing that a
non-comic would say uh I feel like we
have to go yeah you're almost I'm here
on your time we're wrapping up in a
minute yeah okay all right did we get
the chair video or the boat yeah I want
to see the boat brawl
have you covered the [__] baseball
bro no oh it's so sweet it was so sweet
he was like let's go he's like all right
is a punch actually thrown at second
base no one I've never seen anyone
knocked out in a baseball he kind of
went down like he kind of like sniffed
tensed up yeah knocked out most of them
are tough dudes who just don't know how
to throw a punch I remember when Alonzo
Mourning and Larry Johnson if you could
pull that club that's a great funniest
fights neither of them were to throw a
punch yeah Manute Bol was always like
you just get inside him Larry Johnson
manupaul was pretty great
these guys are not they're just ducking
him well I love that the the ref lets it
happen he's like all right [__]
square off
what is this audio
that's why the MLB is so unpopular
let people they let people uh post [__]
that guy back I love how he's like
you've been dirty for a while I've been
waiting for their chance to fight you
yeah did you say that yeah damn after it
showed no regret his own agent showed
him in like boxing gloves it was great
everybody backed that guy he was like
[__] this dirty player Nolan Ryan [__]
up Robin Ventura that was great that was
great that was a good one that stood up
for all rejected yeah fun fact about
that game that's a clip to pull up and I
watched that doc by the way that's a
great dog you know who is the just that
voice over Mike McRae do you guys know
McRae oh Michael Craig great comic
Austin guy yeah he does voice Houston
originally but also the chain ho Park
one is pretty great hey the regs look at
that the Robin Ventura one it was like
the first time pitcher stood up for
himself it was like it was like yeah it
was like time ever no they never [__]
punched hard like that is this Ryan I
don't know why it's six minutes but
there it goes big screen enter is like a
kid too big screen
look at this
oh headlock oh that's the worst oh and
he's like [__] me God damn it I think
Nolan Ryan's like 46 and Robin returns
23 or something wow this old man's
strength another great one is Aaron
Sealy hits George Bell he he charges and
Mo Vaughn comes out of nowhere and
[__] Nails him move on Aaron zealy do
move on
oh he took it well there it comes he
never went down this is a great one uh
four minutes and 40 seconds baseball in
the 90s was so much it was so fun
there's in college did you see the um a
guy lays down a bunt so he could attack
the pitcher left side of the screen
I can't see anything oh
good job move on
that's a fun one look at the melee out
here it's a brouhaha
I think I played that room fights I did
I did a New Year's Eve there one year I
walked up Stitch I opened for you you
walked off stage
yeah why'd you walk off that might have
been 0-9 because they handed out no I
was nearly I was like a month sober it
must have been 2013. oh that was January
2013. guzzling cocktails like there was
no tomorrow I was on I was doing New
Year's Eve and it was a two-man show the
opener did 40 and I was doing 50. that
was the system they came up with so a
guy just walks up cold and does 40
minutes wow and then I was on and at 12
52. I was supposed to take it to
midnight and do the countdown at 12 52
they just start Wheeling out [__]
noise makers and Champagnes oh yeah
and I just walked up I was like I'll
just come back at 11 59. this is insane
yeah and so that's what I did they
always do that it's a mistake they
always make it's so dumb just give them
20 minutes yeah to like say your piece
or whatever make one last apology yeah
oh cereal's weird no we want to
celebrate the ring in the new year with
him I once did a 6 p.m 8 P.M New Year's
night and it's like it was the best New
Year's ever yeah go out do your blow and
[__] enjoy I've been working years
and years yeah it's pointless I love it
the money's better the money's better
but it's lame it's like the show's the
same no one wants to do it either yeah I
all hated them what is this one I
already brought this one up this is a
guy who got uh little chin music and
then he lays down a bunt just so they
can blow up the picture it's a great
great font too oh he knocks him look at
it
and nope never made it to first he got
up though the guy got up another great
one sorry yeah is the Alcantara
do you know that one no she is the right
time Izzy Al yeah there you go just
popped up this is to pay for the
particular Red Sox
before he charges he gets hit we've lost
every female listener ever right here
they're just dudes watching fights we
lost them on our way
the catcher always tries to stop you
oh
wow
that was pretty genius that was pretty
genius pretty good take the catch out of
the equation oh it disappeared him that
never works by the way
yeah all right he goes fishing that
catcher
that guy got it oh that was great I was
so smart you got a face mask I love how
these guys are like when I get hit they
have time to think about it like how
would I I do it differently Ventura was
like and rolling around I was like I'll
put him in a head they always go low he
was just waiting for the chance this guy
was like don't let the catcher catch up
with you I heard the story was venturo
Ventura that guy died this week
no the guy from Ace Ventura oh the
landlord yeah he was on Breaking Bad and
uh and Better Call Saul
should I call you yeah what's up for Ace
Ventura landlord Ventura
fiber fiber he uh what the hell was I
gonna say oh the story about Ventura was
supposedly they had been beefing the
White Sox and Rangers and in the
clubhouse they were like if they throw
at us we're [__] charging them out I
don't care who it is or what it is and
so Ventura this poor kid who just came
up gets hit and was like all right I
guess I got to charge them out and then
this old timer just beats the snot and
continued to pitch in the game I love it
yeah is baseball what is it done no no
baseball's a lot of fun they've changed
this year's gotten better again but uh
as the Yankees get worse baseball gets
better yeah they suck that's true so do
the Red Sox oh we got a melee Yankees
we're supposed to be good I know okay
yeah no the Orioles are [__] good the
Orioles
well Ari's a big Yankee Cowboy Duke
University number one teams number teams
USA uh the Rapier he loves Sweden
women's soccer Penn State sorry okay
negative lacrosse lacrosse yeah yeah all
right they were innocent that's true
not have been great
it's good times with friends well Leah
what do you guys got any plugs we got a
special out there's a few plugs up top
hello
back downstairs hello
it hurt pretty bad I didn't like it yeah
I'll talk to you about it later
going uh show business uh I got a
special out on YouTube right now I
assume it's out right now it's called Uh
uh enough for everybody it's on YouTube
go watch it subscribe there's the one
before that called this year's material
and one before that called I hate myself
look at the baby's name
you already have it what the maybe yeah
he's three months old
by the time by the time this comes out
he might be oh geez she I don't know his
name's Ari uh I got a tour I got a wrong
side History tour coming Parks Casino
Minneapolis Madison Kansas City Iowa
City
Boston that one Casino out here oh
Connecticut uh Foxwoods in Mohegan Sun
Foxwoods yeah Indianapolis Louisville
.com there's your famous pose right
there yeah
I don't know why yeah and you stand like
this sometimes that's true I called you
on a while I said no way oh it's Tempe
Arizona just added in December forget
about that hot town wow all right hey
watch soup tonight
give it a double uh up Vote or whatever
the hell it is [__] trending on in
Netflix the whole yeah it's great
it's Rider strike is helping me out and
uh get some Bodega cat [__] you The
Witcher
now some queefy rom-com is number one
but hey it was only a matter of time uh
and yeah markdiamondcoming.com for dates
I'm all over the road coming to Europe
the whole thing oh nice what do you got
I got Chicago Theater Toronto uh Chicago
Theater
Bethlehem MSG is the big one MSG uh but
uh theater at MSG we got Cleveland Ohio
[__] what is I can't read it you got
Columbus Indianapolis Cincinnati yeah
Cincinnati Indianapolis and then MSG
November 4th yeah don't forget about
Munhall PA that's the big one we call it
Pittsburgh here no one knows
you pulled a Munson all right cues you
got anything to plug
good love to hear it too get your Bodega
cat whiskey Bodega catwhiskey.com I like
coming to one of your parties you don't
have Bodega cat I'm leaving it
hey you heard it here first folks we'll
see you all in hell
[Music]
is close
and and Norman's talking [__] about the
[__] punk and I get down in the same
way
dangerous
[Music]
up to lunch here in New Orleans this
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
[Music]
we might be